hey how's it going bros my name is today
we're reviewing one of the greatest
games of all time one chan one Chen
Berra said to Kaos this game oh boy this
game this game comes with a booklet and
it [ __ ] is it this game has one selling
point sorry
two selling points this is the kind of
game that you don't dare to buy in shame
don't worry I have no shame
just just make sure you delete your
history after this one I clocked about a
hundred hours in this game so without
further ado I'll bring it 1-1 chamber
Chen Chen Vera chaos oh there must there
must be a glitch I swear right nice what
my my save files
don't you kiss you I do sleep at the
comedy so the golden rule of a games
like this is that less clothes means
more armor that [ __ ] are those pansies
man so let me just get this straight
they're they're half naked dole looking
cowboy vampires ten out of ten
oh my [ __ ] Lisa ah what the [ __ ] is
going on the combat is pretty [ __ ]
smooth I gotta say actually enjoy this
oh yeah you can change characters I
remember now
chainsaw school going chainsaw school
girl ripped straight out of bed out of
the game yep I like I like that you can
get a glimpse of their panties that's
that's literally the only reason I do
certain combos this one for example to
get a great penny shot
panties I saw some camel toe in there oh
hello
oh my God look there look at yes you
know someone spent a considerable amount
of time doing this it seems like the
less likely they are to have ever
touched boobs
the better they do them in games oh [ __ ]
what that [ __ ] oh this is pretty [ __ ]
awesome oh that's pretty dope yeah [ __ ]
yeah man oh yeah you're just your dad
Barris how dare you Barris I can [ __ ]
chop barrels in half best game ten out
of ten I actually enjoy this game guys
let's jump over
what oh god I went into I get it I went
into furry mode I think what is
happening what does this mean
sorry my see I don't need you anymore I
just got this game now
I love shark Amal oh god it's happening
again
oh we're almost going into furry mode
what happened what the [ __ ] happened
you think I almost caught a nipple oh
yes yes here's the part
yep
aha what did I say looks like a sonic
come on you stupid stinking moles you
are so dumb you down and Moe's bikinis
plus swords plus zombies plus chainsaws
equals chaos for a femme fatales with
deadly will expose and weapons transform
into Hauer hyper powered beast of
destruction and take zombies apart the
skin all right so now we're playing us
the the the lowly twins okay so so they
serve all the markets you know not only
the people that want to see giant ass
titties but also the ones that have a
strange pedophile obsession they
obviously need to be
my Fuhrer this one because he can see
her panties underneath her skirts when
she does he averaged literally no one
suggested that I would play this game
but it's so perfect it's so perfect I
want to cry I mean there's no challenge
whatsoever like I'm pretty sure it's
impossible to die considering a [ __ ]
overpowered you are when you can't stop
dancing when you wear a pretty dress and
you can't stop dancing when you're a
samurai Vampire Killer and you can't
stop dancing because you're wearing a
pretty dress
oh no beer Trappe sister what should we
do oh look there's a giant demon behind
it they look angry
profit by the vampire sisters that's
right fifteen stupid benches that's
right [ __ ] so happy what is happening
what is happening
what is happening what is happening oh
my god a boss fight yes what is going on
what is going on yes
swipe down I'm swiping them no god oh
god I get too excited oh god what
happened oh I missed it we cut up his
arm and I [ __ ] missed it bear attack
yeah aah chainsaw that bah let's go down
all right every guy ever gonna go man I
swiped it how's that guys I was the guy
expecting to defeat me at this point
like what does he guy they want to kill
me so bad but they they're stuck on a
treadmill don't you hate when you're a
pterodactyl zombie and there's chainsaw
school girls killing you oh hell yeah
why am I keep playing I don't know
you're you're a sonic furry big-breasted
schoolgirl magic samurai the list goes
on you're like one of those people on
twitter who's desperate to show their
achievements so they put like a million
stuff in their bio I want this game to
be played on my funeral and that can
that just be heard right now
I want everyone to play this game so
they'll be happy again we're oh that's
the boss in the middle we're [ __ ] her
up look at that [ __ ] that's what you
get for ruining our floor which way to
my swipe I can I can swipe all day so
nice panties amazing
if anyone knows what I'm looking at
right now feel free to tell me
pretty sure this is how Jesus was born
but that's it for now for one channel
Brad of Z to chaos ten out of ten
I am DB best game rated 10 thank you so
much for watching
like what like if you enjoyed of course
you did and I'll see you brush in the
next one
stay awesome press Breanna it's Friday
morning and school was already in the
process but as usual I needed my morning
coffee so that my brain can function
normally I was on my way to the coffee
shop when I saw someone very very
familiar wait oh my god